the sharks of the Abaco islands are fast
agile and
Powerful normally they leave humans
alone but in
2018 Everything
Changes a terrifying Spade of shark
attacks turns this island paradise
upside down until the mystery is solved
your next Caribbean vacation could be
your
last the abacos are a really special
place incredibly relaxing the people are
lovely really
welcoming British couple Kate and Jason
insb have been coming on vacation to
this remote island chain for over 20
years it's the most adorable magical
Serene place nestled along the northern
edge of the Bahamas about 283 miles from
the coast of Florida the Abaco islands
are known for their stunning beaches
Crystal Blue Waters and spectacular
marine
life home to 50 varieties of coral and
several hundred kinds of fish the region
is one of the Premier diving sites in
the world everything about the abacos
gives a fantastic relaxing holiday a
really good way to recharge your
batteries but tourists are not the only
ones drawn to these
waters shars are everywhere we grew up
with them when we were kids we swam with
them not deliberately but we swam with
them they're around here all the time
patrolling the region are more than 40
species of shark like the bizarrely
shaped
Hammerhead the silky shark named for its
unusually smooth
skin and the Magnificent ocean white tip
most of the time these fearsome Hunters
leave locals and tourists
alone but not any
more K and Jason are enjoying a peaceful
vacation with family and friends we were
on holiday that time with another family
and quite regularly in the early morning
you know just after Dawn we would go to
a certain Beach and feed the turtles but
what starts as Another Day in Paradise
will end in horror this particular
morning we fed the turtles they'd come
and eaten from our hands as normal and
we'd seen as shark in the distance but
to be honest none of us were at all
worried because we'd had so many
encounters with sharks when we'd been on
snorkeling trips so we didn't think
there was anything to worry about the
shark closes in on Kate and her
daughters it was you know maneuvering
around it came right up in the water and
swam almost sort of you know across them
making physical contact with them I
think that was the first time I'd seen a
shark do that
before my daughter said you know you're
probably best to just stand still rather
than worry it by suddenly moving and
spooking it it did a few little circuits
swam around a bit and then it came up to
me and
just bit my leg the Predator sinks its
teeth into Kate's
calf which was incredibly
painful I immediately went running out
of the water using language I definitely
better not use now with my daughter
running after
me and then you know my blood ran cold I
mean that was just a horrible
feeling we got out of the water then to
find exactly what had happened which was
pretty nasty I looked down and it looked
like sort of part of my leg was hanging
out it was quite a
shock Kate's family rushes her to a
nearby Clinic where she's treated for a
large bite on her lower left leg a few
days later she returns to the UK and
eventually makes a full recovery it was
a long process because it was a hole
rather than a sort of jagged wound so
they had to just allow it to heal I
suppose From the Inside
Out shark attacks on the Abaco islands
are extremely rare and Kate's attack
takes locals and Visitors by surprise
but little do they know it's just the
beginning 5 days later a second tourist
is bitten and a few weeks after that a
third attack sends the community into
panic mode three attacks in just over a
month it's unheard of three shock
attacks in 40 days is rare because most
of the times we don't hear much shocks
attack in the Bahamas so if we hear that
much like attacks that's that's very
rare the reason for the sudden spike in
attacks is a mystery locals and tourists
alike are desperate for
answers until the reason for the rise in
attacks is uncovered no one is safe I
think it's important to investigate
these because is this just a rogue shark
is this something that needs to be
actually worried about more so it's very
important to figure out what's going
on shark attacks have plagued The Wider
Bahamian archipelago in the
past and the Sharks most commonly
responsible are among the world's
deadliest like the tiger shark with its
razor sharp teeth which can rip through
flesh bone and even the shells of sea
turtles and the pugnacious bull shark
known for its
ferocity bull sharks can weigh up to a
ton and their jaws can exert almost 500
lb of force they're around here all the
time they cruise up and down this Coast
we have Hammerheads since I've been here
30 years this one Hammerhead has been
cruising here every summer it's about
18t long key to solving the mystery is
determining which species are
involved Dr Dan Huber of the University
of Tampa takes up the investigation and
immediately zeros in on a crucial piece
of evidence in this photo of Kate and
the shark immediately before the attack
you can see the shape of its pectoral
fins you can see the long tail coming
off of its body and its compressed body
form there is only one shark whose
Anatomy fits this description so we can
absolutely identify that this is a nurse
shark right next to Kate's leg moments
before she was
attacked nurse sharks are found in
tropical oceans around the
world they grow up to about 9 ft long
and spent almost all of their life
hunting for food on the sea floor
they're also suction feeders and what
that means is that when they find prey
they open their mouths really fast and
generate a negative pressure that then
sucks water and the prey into their
mouth an examination of the bite marks
on Kate's leg confirms the culprit when
we look at Kate's wound what we see is a
circular wound with a series of
abrasions that show all of these tiny
little markings almost as though she had
been hit on the leg with a meat
tenderizer and all of those little
markings are the evidence of all of
those tiny little teeth that lie in the
inner surface of a nurse shark's Jaws
for Dr Huber it's an unusual finding
nurse shark sh s are definitely not
known to be an aggressive species in
fact they're actually known to be a
fairly gentle species of sharks it's not
uncommon for people to interact with
them closely out in the ocean with no
incident why are these docel sharks
suddenly attacking
people some locals think it all comes
down to who is being
bitten it's very seldom you hear locals
getting bitten by sharks most of the
times when you hear stuff like that
occurring it's usually been tourists or
a water it I think generally because
people get comfortable a detail from
Kate's attack suggests there might be
some truth to the idea I think our whole
family felt confident in going in the
water with sharks around and I
particularly actually had always been
confident if we were on a beach I would
just swim straight out to sea not
thinking really about what might be in
the water Kate's friends even snapped
photos of the very shark that bit her
moments before the attack back I guess
they thought they were getting great
photos and it didn't occur to them that
there was any issue I genuinely think
that we were very complacent you know
we're so used to seeing sharks around we
call it brain you can become so
relaxed so quickly it feels like you're
sort of you've turned to Mush and you
can't remember really what's going on
you know what day of the week it is the
CYO brain you know that's how you feel
are tourists becoming so relaxed that
they ignore the dangers around them
making them easy prey for the ocean's
top
predators it sounds outlandish but could
it be
true Al Teresa Clark is a licensed
trauma therapist who studies human
behavior we all have three kind of
compasses in our mind they're called the
id ego and super ego and our ID is
basically our Basic Instincts it's our
inhibitions that we're lowering when
you're on vacation you're not really
thinking about a a shark might attack me
you're really thinking about the moment
I'm feeding sea turtles I'm deep sea
diving and you're not really thinking of
a lot of the precautions that you
normally would in your day-to-day life
and that false sense of security is a
contributing factor to shark attacks
could human complacency be the reason
behind the unusual uptick in shark
attacks it's very easy to judge people
in those instances but we've all been
there we've all all been at a place in
our life where we have not made sound
decisions and it's not fair to judge
it's a psychological phenomenon that
happens to all of
us Dr Yannis papasu from Florida
International University weighs in she
was obviously very comfortable with this
animal in the water and I would say on
the one hand that's good I'm glad we've
gotten to a point where people are
comfortable with sharks you don't have
to see a shark in the water and freak
out that you're going to get eaten but
we also don't want this sort of opinion
of them that they're your pets or
they're your friends because they're not
it's just a wild animal it's a
[Music]
predator every person myself included
engages in Risky behavior of some form
or another because on some level we all
think we're at least a little bit
Invincible if you take the case of
Kate's attack she clearly was very
comfortable being in the water with that
Nerf shark she simply let it swim up to
her and then ultimately just bite her
and so to be that close to a shark in
the water and not create some kind of
distance between you and that
potentially dangerous animal I think
reflects a certain amount of complacency
that we have when we're on vacation when
all we're looking to do is have a good
time but there's a
problem tourists have been coming to the
Abaco islands for decades without
incident and the spike and attacks
occurred over a specific 40-day period
in
complacency can't explain the disturbing
uptick in
attacks as locals struggle for answers
another attack sends shock waves across
the islands and this time the attack is
caught on
[Music]
video you copy yeah we copy my family is
from Florida my dad grew up with a love
for the ocean and we inherited that as
kids a lot of our family vacations were
spent uh on the beach on a boat fishing
snorkeling enjoying the ocean I've been
on a Bahamas trip with you probably a
dozen times for Outdoorsman will Krauss
the Abaco islands are like a second home
when I was 21 we started fallen in love
with the Bahamas and we fell in love
with the specific area of the abacos the
abacos are a wild place you don't see a
lot of other boats there it's pretty
rural the fishing there is really good
the water Clarity is unbelievable but in
2018 the fisherman becomes the
prey we planned a 4-day trip with a lot
of my
co-workers we got the divers in the
water just got acclimated to the weather
the weather was great water was clear
will dad stays on the boat while will
and his friends head out in search of
fish and as with most of their Dives in
the Abaco Islands there are
sharks we make a lot of promises to our
spouses to be safe and once the
captain's notified that a diver spots a
shark uh we have a no shoot protocol at
that point and we usually travel a mile
or so uh away from where we saw that
shark and then fish again will and his
friends find what seems to be a safe
spot but in these Waters looks can be
deceiving hadn't seen a lot of fish on
the particular Rock I was uh on but my
buddy Zach and his crew were chasing a
hogfish I was running low on air and
ready to come back up and uh when I
heard the shot go off and 3 seconds
later I felt a huge impact on my head I
wasn't sure what what had happened from
just a few feet away Will's buddy
catches the attack on
camera a shark has locked its jaws
around Will's head I was certain I was
dead the only thing that made sense to
me was that the boat prop had somehow
hit me in the back of the head and so I
was convinced that I had been run over
by the
boat I was not thinking
shark one of the swimmers came up out of
the water and scream shark shark shk
shark can hear in the video me say what
happened my buddy Zach says a shark a
shark got you shark I can see Will and
he was swimming to the boat but he was
holding his
head my dad clocked it I believe it was
13 seconds from bite to everybody was in
the boat it happened in a
hurry
I remember opening my eyes and looking
at the back of the boat and realizing
that's my blood all over the back of
this boat once ashore will is treated at
a local Clinic where he receives nine
stitches to close the wounds I had
lacerations in my neck I have teeth
marks on the top of my head that start
about where my ear is and the biggest
scar that you could really see was the
backs side of my uh neck there's some
pretty gnarly scars there that are my
souvenirs from the uh encounter will and
his dad are forever changed by the
attack 3 years after we planned a trip
back oddly enough we had an encounter
with about an 8ot Caribbean reef shark
came in hot we really think that it
might have been the same shark we got
out and pretty much decided we're not
going to swim that particular Rock
anymore the ocean is a very
unpredictable place and the element of
unscripted that you love about it is
also that part
um just
dangerous in search of
Clues Dr Huber reviews the video shot by
Will's buddy sh sh sh and immediately
hones in on the shark that bit
will what caused will and the other
Abaco Island victims to be attacked
there's a variety of what are known as
carared sharks that all look very very
similar but many of them have
distinguishing attributes for example
black tip sharks have black tips on
their fins black tip sharks are common
along the Atlantic coast of Florida as
well as in the
Bahamas they are best known for a
spectacular hunting Behavior where they
leap out of the water when striking at a
school of
fish but the shark in the video is not a
black tip when we look at the video of
will krauss's attack what we see is a
carared shark but one that doesn't have
these distinguishing attributes and
because of this we can identify it as a
Caribbean reef
shark Caribbean reef sharks are abundant
in the shallow coral reefs of the region
they grow to be about 6t long and while
they mostly feed on small bony fish they
have also been known to attack
swimmers it's a critical breakthrough in
the investigation because whatever is
causing the increase in attacks a fects
multiple species of
shark what's causing the shark's
aggressive
behavior a clue might lie in a seemingly
minor detail of Will's
attack I had heard the shot go off on
the
fish and by the time I was able to spin
around and and see where they were the
shark had hit
me
moments before will Was Bitten one of
his buddies discharged a spear and shot
a
fish so how might this simple sequence
of events be linked to the
attack it all comes down to one of the
shark's most important
senses
hearing humans have external ears which
funnel sounds into our eardrums and and
then our eardrums pass those
environmental sounds into our sensory
mechanisms sharks don't have external
ears but sound waves can still enter
their head go into their inner ear and
then stimulate the sensory mechanism in
the same way a shark's inner ear is
coated with a layer of tiny hair cells
when sound waves reach these cells they
vibrate and send signals to the brain
which the brain interprets as
sound just like humans what sharks
actually hear are VI
vibrations but in this case of the
attack on will it's less about how
sharks hear rather than what they hear
now sharks hear things using the same
basic mechanism that we do it's just
tuned to lower frequencies like the
frequencies that would be found out in
the open ocean our sensitivity range is
more on the order of about 2,000 to
5,000 Hertz shark hearing is more on the
order of about 25 to 1500
Hertz according to Dr Steven kajura of
Florida Atlantic University the reason
sharks are attuned to these lower
frequencies is because they're the same
sounds made by injured fish when fish
are speared they will struggle on the
spear and they will uh swim erratically
this produces a lot of low frequency
sound something like struggling low
frequency it also produces nearfield
particle vibrations in the water and
both of these are a stimuli to the
sharks sharks are tuned to detect these
sorts of stimuli and use them to
localize pre to demonstrate this in
action Dr kajura recreates an
extraordinary experiment devised more
than 40 years ago in the past scientists
have actually recorded the sound of a a
wounded grouper underwater and we have
those recordings we're able to play
those back from the computer uh through
an amplifier and then to an underwater
speaker which projects the sound and
we're able to film The response of the
sharks from an overhead drone and look
at how the Sharks Orient toward this
sound
when the experiment was first conducted
the results were conclusive the Sharks
swam directly towards the sound of the
injured
fish could the sound of struggling fish
on the end of a spear gun have drawn
sharks to the attack sites in a beating
frenzy the speared fish would have been
giving off a lot of low frequency sounds
that would have drawn the attention of a
to the area but there is one piece of
evidence that doesn't fit in the theory
in the case of Will's attack he wasn't
the one who shot the fish sh sh Shar why
would he be the one to be bitten in that
moment I actually didn't think it was a
shark I was convinced that I'd been run
over by the
boat the sound of the struggling fish
can't fully explain the attack or the
spike but will and his dad think they
can shark shark
shark if you look closely in the video
I'm starting to
ascend and the Sharks the blow and the
speed in which he hits me throws my head
almost into the sand like I I go from
coming up to being my head thrown
directly into the ocean floor it felt
like a baseball bat just teed off on me
hit me from behind you will
up since the attack B and his dad have
developed an intriguing Theory to
explain why he was bitten you were right
Shar this was a shark that came in hot
and he didn't really have a lot of
reasons from our Behavior to do that he
passed on the fish he passed on the very
small Hogfish to bite will will believes
the shark had a very specific motive
when it attacked him my personal opinion
from this encounter was that the shark
was motivated by the fish that was
shot but viewed me as a as a threat to
that I think he considered me another
shark so was running me off shark shark
Shar throwing a punch at me to get me
out of the area so that he could go back
and have his
meal if Will's theory is right it would
suggest that sharks are willing to
defend their feeding grounds when
threatened
Dr Steven kessle has been tracking
Caribbean reef sharks in the Bahamas
since
2017 his findings suggest there might be
some truth to Will's
hypothesis that data shows us very
conclusively that these this species is
very sight attached to specific areas
within a given Reef system they stay
focused around a 3 to 5 km section of
that wreath so that leads to a lot of
competition for resources between both
reef sharks and other species of sharks
or any predator that may enter that
system Dr kessle believes that Caribbean
reef sharks are
territorial according to Dr yanis
papastamatiou an expert in predatory
behavior at Florida International
University some sharks will aggressively
defend what they perceive as theirs you
do see that s we white sharks for
example where a bigger white shark will
bite a smaller one if it feels like that
white shark's trying to take some of its
food
in 2021 a marine photographer captured
extraordinary footage of a great white
covered with terrible bite
marks the video sparked a host of
theories as to what had bitten this
predator and why some experts believe
that this shark was involved in a
violent struggle over food with a larger
more aggressive shark are the sharks of
the Caribbean locked in in a turf war
with humans over
fish sometimes when Reef shars do show
aggression they'll do quite
characteristic behaviors like they'll
drop their pector fins maybe they'll
arch their back and they'll swim in a
sort of strange
fashion Dr papati takes a closer look at
the footage from Wills attack difference
is that for hunting you can see it comes
in very fast and is sort of changing
direction very rapidly but generally
what I'm seeing here is a shark that is
coming in to get
prey he believes the key to
understanding what's going on is reading
a shark's body
language in his opinion the shark wasn't
defending its territory it was actively
hunting now you see it bit once on the
head and then obviously realize that it
is not what it was expecting and then
let's go and uh Le the area
right one of the problems with trying to
assign intentions to shark behavior is
that often we can project our own human
behaviors and human feelings onto these
animals for example when will and his
father thought that from the Sharks
perspective will represented competition
for food in that environment we really
have no way of understanding what was
going on in that shark's head so we
really can't infer what that shark was
thinking as the motivation for its
behaviors during that
attack a battle over territory isn't the
cause of the spike in
attacks and while investigators search
for answers the danger to Swimmers at
these tropical waters is all too
real I think people are worried when
there's Shak I think a lot of people
become worried in a sense that okay it's
going to affect that the the the tourism
industry and I think that's one of the
main thing that people focus on the
thousands and thousands of sharks out
there I'm not going in there with
them a third attack contains a gruesome
[Music]
clue it's early Sunday afternoon and a
32-year-old American woman is out spear
fishing now she had gone g into the
water and she had speared a hogfish but
the Hogfish had gotten away and swam
into a
cave as she went in to follow the
Hogfish she soon realized that she was
in trouble because there was a large
shark closing in on her the shark bit
down on her left
hand her hand and fingers are ripped
open by the
shark fortunately this woman was able to
get back to to the boat and get medical
attention in
time the victim is airlifted to a
Florida hospital for
treatment this is the third terrifying
incident in just 40 days off the Abaco
Islands but on this occasion the shark
itself left behind an important
clue a tooth fragment embedded in the
victim's hand and when the fragment is
analyzed it's shown to come from one of
the most notorious predators in the
region the black tip
shark these are jaws from a 6ot black
tip shark and when we take a look at
them we can see that all of the teeth
have relatively thin cusps what this
means is that they're going to sink into
prey really really easily but also that
they can actually break off pretty
easily in fact you can see a couple of
the tooth tips which are broken off
right over here so because of the shape
of the teeth this is likely why the
victim actually found a tooth fragment
broken off in her
wound black tip sharks are one of the
most common species throughout the
Western Atlantic Ocean they're found
from as far north as Massachusetts and
as far south as Brazil they're
responsible for about 5% of shock
attacks worldwide including multiple
attacks in the
Bahamas a nurse shark a Caribbean reef
shark and now a black te tip the
addition of a third species to the list
of culprits could be vital to solving
the
mystery investigators turn to shark
behaviorist Christina zenato in the hope
that her Decades of dive experience with
a shiver of sharks will help solve the
case a shiver is the English word used
to represent a group of sharks so you
have a school of fish on a flock of
birds on a shiver of
sharks with nearly 10,000 shark Dives
under her belt Christina has unique
insight into the species that inhabit
the
Bahamas I've been working with Caribbean
re sharks in the Bahamas for the last 27
years and as I became more and more
involved with the work of the Caribbean
R sharks I first realized uh what kind
of C perceptions people had of sharks
and furthermore how very little we knew
about them and so I started collecting
data on the daytoday presence of
specific individuals and collected this
log of these shiver of sharks that I've
been working with for all these years
these animals actually have
personalities and have
differences each and every one of the
species behaves differently on a
different day like a little bit like us
right we wake up we have the good night
sleep we're okay we have the bad night
sleep we're not okay so sharks are very
much affected by their environment
they're very much affected by our
presence and our actions one size does
not fit
all Christina revisits the attack on
will Krauss in search of any crucial
details that might have been overlooked
sh sh sh
and what she uncovers could unravel the
mystery once and for all I watch it
again the person Spears the fish and
then starts pulling the fish up and the
fish goes into this erratic
movement so the Caribbean RAR comes in
for that and then does a quick beine in
a certain for the aod diary that is
kneeling down on the ocean floor what
Christina spots is crucial to the
investigation and it hinges around a
single piece of
clothing Will's hoodie it has this light
collar like blue color over his head
which underwater are the colors of of
death anything that dies on water turns
into this light blue
color while it's believed that sharks
cannot see color they do have an
incredible ability to respond to changes
in contrast and
brightness according to Christina the
light blue hue of Will's hoodie is just
the right shade to catch a shark's
attention the Sharks only has a split
second what is the closest thing that
looks to the prey that is looking for
which is the round head coveron of blue
ler I heard it I smell it it's moving
really fast where is it oh there's
something light color bite as I o no
it's not it and that's how I see the the
bite happening what stood out to me was
that he was wearing this sort of white
hoodie and that was also going over his
head and so that was creating sort of a
contrast in colors so I believe at that
point when that shark is in that sort of
Fring State it's just going to respond
to any sort of stimulus it sees so it
could have been that that color contrast
just overwhelmed in terms of a sensory
stimulus and that's what initiated that
bite oh you were right
while high contrast clothing is thought
to play a role in some human shark
encounters There's Something About This
theory that doesn't add up the fact of
the matter is that in the other attacks
in Avo the victims weren't wearing light
color clothing so light colored clothing
can't be the only Factor contributing to
these spikes and
attacks the cause of the three
terrifying shark attacks in the
Island Spike remains a
mystery EXP birts are baffled and locals
are hungry for answers if we have about
three shock attacks within within a span
of 40 days we're going to stay over the
waters perhaps the sudden surge could be
rooted in a dramatic set of changes that
occurred here more than a decade
earlier changes that were designed to
benefit both shark and tourist but may
have had the opposite
effect people come to the Bahamas for
dive experiences those experiences are
enhanced by the fact that they see large
Predators on our reefs in 2003 shark
fishing was banned off the coast of the
Bahamas including the Abaco Islands the
result is a protected shark Sanctuary
that's still in place today even though
we are a small island State we consider
oursel a large Ocean State and that
large ocean that we're responsible for
fortunately had very healthy shark
populations that had not been targeted
by fishermen we had the great
opportunity and fortunately the
government of Bahamas jumped on it acted
quickly and um you know we had a shark
sanctuary in record
time many locals believe that the shark
Sanctuary had a drastic effect on the
number of sharks in the area since the
sanctuary has been set in place there's
definitely been an increase in
population I've been spear fishing many
times and they've been surrounding me in
the last 10 years especially I believe
that we've seen a significant increase
in uh in the shark
populations and uh in encounters with
them the connection between the number
of sharks in the water and the number of
attacks is well
established on Cape Cod for example an
increase in the great white population
in the past decade resulted in an
upsurge in deadly shark
attacks is the same pattern emerging
here like once we pull up and we'll just
kind of hover over the spot the shark
should start circling around the boat
shark experts Dr Steven kessle Matt
Smule and shark dive guide Brian roll
head out to test the theory you guys
ready y yeah all
right Matt Buckle is the head researcher
at the bimin shark lab which has been
tracking shark populations in Bahamian
waters for 35
years there they come another one here
yeah see like three or four already
pretty big one the way the shark lab
tracks the abundance of sharks really
depends on the species one of the ones
that the shark lab has run for 35 years
now are our survey lines we set hooks
out there and we count how how many
sharks we're
catching and the numbers tell a
surprising story our data shows that the
numbers of sharks in the area are very
stable for the past 35 years we also
have to remember that sharks are a
longli species that have very slow
reproductive cycle so it's actually
biologically not possible that they're
going to Boom Out of Control just in the
past 10
years they're all very already very
healthy sharp populations probably close
to the limit of what this ecosystem is
able to support so the establishment of
the Shar Sentry did not cause a dramatic
increase in Shar populations it just
sustained already very healthy Shar
populations after looking at these three
instances none of them have anything to
do with there being a boom in shark
populations there's no data to back that
up the establishment of the shark
Sanctuary is not behind the spike
investiga race to find an answer before
it's too
late in the quest to solve the puzzle
investigators turned to a seemingly
insignificant detail from the first
attack in the spike that of Kate inip
quite regularly in the early morning you
know just after Dawn we would go to a
certain Beach and feed the
turtles I had just rinsed out the
container just in the sea but I was
still holding it when the shark
came perhaps the shark could have seen
it I don't know it's the only thing I
can see that could have differentiated
me from the other people in the
water a container holding Frozen squid
but how might this simple vessel unravel
the reason for the attacks it comes down
to how sharks
smell a shark's nose is uniquely adapted
to detect odor in the
water when we look at the side of a
shark's head we can see it's nostril
right here and the nostril has two
openings there's an opening where water
flows into it and then a flap and then
an opening where the water flows out of
it as water flows into the nose it
activates sensory cells which send to
the brain we can see the front of the
brain which is called the cerebrum
that's an area which processes all of
the odor information that's associated
with the sense of smell so when a shark
detects something that's useful to it
such as the smell of a prey item it's
going to start swimming back and forth
and back and forth to try to pick up on
higher and higher concentrations of that
chemical to demonstrate how this works
Dr kajura sets up a simple experiment
what we want to do is demonstrate the
behavioral response of these animals
when they detect a food odor in the
water and so to do that we're going to
take an acrylic plate and lower it down
into the tank with a long tube and we're
going to be able to use that to
introduce odor sources on the bottom
where these sharks are naturally hunting
these sharks have a very sensitive old
factory system they're able to detect
odors down to like a part per billion
that's the equivalent of being able to
detect a single drop of blood in an
Olympic siiz swimming
pool flip the three-way valve fill the
syringe with Squid juice like
this you should start to see a little
plume coming
out okay see how he's searching around
now zipping back and forth with his head
on the bottom if you look at the tail
bead frequency they're swimming faster
now than they were when they're just
cruising through the
tank here we've got one coming up this
way following the odor toward the The
Source here both of them in fact look at
that turning see how that turned
Upstream toward the source of the uh
odor definitely interested in something
here the conclusion is clear Kate's
container of squid may have been the
exact thing that Drew the shark to her
we demonstrated these sharks are highly
sensitive to food orders and it makes
sense these sharks are naturally attuned
to finding prey items and so they have
evolved to find preout in the wild in
Kate's case she had just rinsed out a
bucket full of food odor in the water
and that odor plume was all around her
as a result these sharks were zipping
around trying to find the source of that
odor and uh she happened to be right in
the middle of it and that's why she
ended up being bitten the squid juice is
the final clue that unlocks the secret
to the spike in
attacks with this evidence Dr Huber
notices a single common factor in each
of the three 2018
attacks these three attacks involved
either hand feeding animals in the ocean
or spear fishing and in all three cases
there was chemical information that was
being put into the ocean that would have
attracted sharks because their sense of
smell is queued into the specific
chemicals that were spilling into the
ocean in each of these
situations odor could this be the final
piece to the puzzle
odor is one of the key things that
attract sharks to their prey odors
travel over long distances and sharks
have very sensitive senses of smell
which means that they can queue in to
those signals follow them to their
source and that ultimately leads them to
their food the evidence points to the
swimming behavior of sharks becoming
more aggressive when odor is introduced
to the surrounding
water
the video of will krauss's attack shows
the shark swimming in the same way as
did the shark that attacked Kate inip
the fact that it was digging under my
feet it then swam around it was coming
up to the surface it was showing much
more interest in us than I would have
expected order is a key sensory modality
for sharks when it comes to feeding here
we've got one coming up this way
following the odor toward the source
here
both of them in fact and so any odor in
the water would be one of the Prime
motivators to get these sharks to start
searching for food and if the people are
in the wrong place at the wrong time
that's how they end up being
bit while there are a variety of factors
that could have contributed to the spike
and shark attacks in the Avo Islands the
one common denominator that goes across
all three attacks was odors going into
the water in each of those cases there
was chemical odor information going to
the environment which sharks are
attracted to and investigated the source
of leading to the attacks with this
final piece of evidence the mystery
behind the Abaco Island's dramatic spike
is
[Music]
solved